Madison Spokane Washington hi Matt how
are you oh I'm not doing great right now
Oh what's going on what happened
33 pulmonary embolism oh my lord
she had an 8 centimeter blood caught in
one of her lungs and didn't know it
no she was putting away groceries with
our daughter and our daughter came to
get me and told us that mommy said oh no
one fell over oh my goodness hold your
daughter and so you were on baby step
two and you said you got life insurance
it's on the way then yeah two policies I
found out one for $100 and one for
500,000 mm how old are you I'm 37 how
long were you guys married you know what
I tell folks to do in these situations
let's be very careful to do nothing but
just just give yourself some room to cry
you know I don't think if your 33 year
old wife passes away suddenly
unexpectedly last week that anyone would
expect you to make really good decisions
today I know if that happened to Sharon
we've been married 38 years I getting
ready to be 38 I I wouldn't be able to
breathe for a little while and just
listening to you you can't even breathe
real good right now and I don't blame
you I understand
so here's what I want you to do okay I
want you to keep food in the house and
pay the lights and pay the water bill
and pay the house payment and any other
payments you guys have just go ahead and
pay those but don't make any big
financial decisions right now just
breathe it's gonna take but it's gonna
take you these six months for your brain
to work right again does that make sense
to you and all that makes sure is not a
bad person it just makes you a human
okay
none of us none of us when we get hit
this hard
those are do we think well for a while
and so we're gonna give you we're gonna
give you a little time for the fog to
clear all right
and do nothing do nothing for a little
while now yeah so all you got to do is
just eat and feed your baby and hug your
baby that's all you do and you got six
out of it and you put six hundred
thousand in the bank and you don't touch
it for anything don't buy anything don't
travel
don't blow any money don't touch that
money just forget that it's there for
six months and this is this is September
and so we're gonna say in March when the
spring comes out and the flowers come
out in the grass is coming out again and
it starts getting a little warmer then
we'll start thinking about this but
we're gonna take from now until then to
breathe again
is that okay half our income last page
that came today
okay so what do you make I make well
it's gonna change at the end of this
month but I was making about 63 jumped
to 75 at the end of this month and you
can't you can't live on that she was
absolutely the nerd in our relationship
okay I'll tell you what we're gonna do
I'm gonna put you with one of my
financial coaches that's been through
our training and I'm gonna pay for it so
I don't cost you anything and they're
gonna sit down with you and help you put
your budget together and help you get on
track okay I think you can live on 75
I don't have another details but I think
you can make it on your 75 and then
let's not touch let's not touch the
other money until until you until you
kind of get clear where you can breathe
again and then we'll probably just you
know what we're probably doing marches
we'll just advance you through the baby
steps you know will pay off everything
and we'll you know pay off the house and
probably that kind of stuff but we're
not gonna do that today today we're just
gonna cry is that okay sometimes you
know what happens is you just need room
to cry and I'm just telling you take
room you got room there's nothing here
in the finances that you're giving me
that causes me to panic there's nothing
to be afraid of
other than we've just got to be able to
get our arms around some of the details
and keep the household running but you
can do that and we'll help okay we're
gonna walk alongside you we're not gonna
do it for you but we're gonna walk
alongside you
yeah be part of your healing and this
time okay okay you can do this and you
call it you call me back if you need any
help - okay okay and we'll put you on
hold stay on and Kelly's gonna pick up
and we're gonna get you set up with one
of our coaches so hang on the line with
me open phones at triple 8 8 2 5 5 2 2 5
you jump in and we'll talk about your
life and your money Wow
you just I mean I don't know how to
recover after that what do you say
that's intelligent for that you can't
there anything since a it's intelligent
after that ouch
unbelievable if that doesn't make you go
home and hug your spouse tonight then
you aren't listening closely if that
doesn't make you say I'm gonna get my
financial house in order so that if God
forbid something happened then my family
will be taken care of making sure you
have the proper amount of life insurance
in place how much different is that
phone call if there's not six hundred
thousand dollars in the mail
be different could be very different but
there's nothing to worry about there is
there nothing not financially lots of
other stuff to worry about
you got a baby standing in the kitchen
when our mama passed that's enough to
worry about right so that's why you have
you know $600,000 and term life
insurance that's why you have your will
in place and that's why both of you are
involved in handling the money both of
you all honey you're good at it you just
take care of it that sound like much of
a plan after that call nope it's called
grown-up land you're both supposed to
know what's going on with the money he
knows more than he's letting on he's in
better shape than he's just hurting he's
gonna be okay but you need to know I'm
the nerd at my house and my wife needs
to know about the money you're the nerd
at your house your free spirit needs to
know about the money and what's going on
and we have to lay out a plan you know
and it's not well I'm just flipping my
life I don't want to think about well
it's time to be growing up I'm sorry
unless you're living in your mama's
basement she's taking care of you then
you're gonna have to be a grown-up here
I have to take care of you and that's
what this stuff does because what poor
Matt and his family are going through is
what all of us go through at different
times in one way or another don't we
none of you none of us are getting out
of this alive and so we got to have a
plan I don't want to talk about I don't
care if you want to talk about it or not
there talk about it now now it's the
time to talk about it while you can
whether somebody talk to about it
lay your will out go over with your
family what the will says make sure
that's done today
but your life insurance in place today
make sure both of you are on the same
page about money today
thank goodness Matt and his wife are
doing most of those things then making
it easier yeah actually does make it
easier one less thing to worry about
while your heart is breaking you have to
worry about your house being foreclosed
on while your hearts breaking that's a
bit more of a problem isn't it it's how
this stuff works in the real world boys
and girls ouch this is the Dave Ramsey
show